Back in April, I made a couple of
interrelated videos. One about why I
believe Muhammad existed and one about
why Muslims are not phased by claims
otherwise. In those videos, I briefly
but respectfully mentioned the name of
Dr. J. Smith as the man spearheading the
claim that Muhammad never existed. And
now J. Smith has responded.
>> I'm going to shut him down. If you're
watching, Raymond Hibuin, thank you for
doing this because finally I have an
academic who's actually taking me on on
these subjects
>> in two videos, no less. each two hours
long. It was therefore with great
anticipation that I watched the first
one where he delivers a presentation
inside a church. It was not long,
however, before I became a bit
disappointed. Why, in a word, straw man.
Many, many straw men. For those unaware,
a straw man argument or fallacy is when
person A, Rey, makes an argument and
person B, Jay, responds by
misrepresenting that argument in a way
that makes it much easier to knock down.
That is like knocking down a helpless
straw man instead of a real man. Take
this list of 10 points that Jay says I
made and merely look at the very first
one. It reads, quote, "Muhammad is one
of the most historically supported
people in history." According to Jay,
that's what I said and believe. Now, to
understand how preposterous this claim
is and thus easily knocked over like a
straw man, focus especially on the
latter end of that sentence in history.
Not in ancient history, not in late
antiquity, not in medieval history. No,
he's saying in history. He's essentially
saying that I'm claiming that a man from
the shadowy 7th century is better
documented than oh, I don't know, Ronald
Reagan, Adolf Hitler, Winston Churchill,
all of whom are figures in history. What
I did claim and still do is that by the
7th century standards of recorded
history, which are abysmally low in
comparison to the written records of
subsequent centuries, there is much
compelling evidence that Muhammad
existed, namely over a dozen
contemporary, mostly Christian
references to him. And there are all
written between 2 and 30 years after his
death. As I said in my video, by the
standards of the seventh century, a time
from which very few records survive,
that is remarkably solid evidence for
his existence. What I did not say is
that quote, "Muhammad is one of the most
historically supported people in
history." I hope you see the difference
and why my claim is as strong as a claim
Jay attributes to me is weak. So weak
that he can easily knock it down.
Moving along, here's the second claim
Jay attributes to me. quote, "Muhammad
has more historical support than Jesus."
That's what I supposedly said and
believe. Again, note the broad
generalization, historical support. What
I said was a lot more nuanced than that.
Here's the point I was actually making
in the video. When mainstream historians
talk about religious figures, they
always cite and give much more credence
to historical sources written by
non-believers rather than believers.
Thus, when it comes to determining
whether Christ actually existed, a
question that, as I noted in my video,
many non-Christians have long disputed,
so-called objective historians tend to
dismiss the New Testament outright.
Their reasoning, these texts are
allegedly too biased, written by men
with an obvious agenda to convert others
to belief in Jesus. Add to that the
presence of miracles, and the documents
are considered even less credible.
According to this view, only references
to Jesus by non-Christians are deemed
trustworthy. This supposedly is the
rigorous scholarly standard. But as it
happens, we do have non-Christian
references to Christ. I mentioned them
in my video. Josephus, Plenty the
Younger, and Tacitus, all of whom
mentioned Jesus in their writings
between 60 and 83 years after Christ's
crucifixion. It was at that point that I
said again I find it amazing that
whereas Christians rightfully cite
Joseph's ply and Tacitus as early proof
of Christ's existence the references to
Muhammad which objectively speaking are
even more compelling having been written
much closer to their subject's lifetime
2 years not 60 are dismissed as
irrelevant by those who would make him a
figment of our imagination but that's
not how Jay represented my position is
it? He completely ignored the central
point that historians overwhelmingly
prefer the testimony of non-believers
and that I was simply conforming to
their logic to make a broader point.
Instead, he pivoted to something else
entirely, claiming that the New
Testament was written much closer to
Jesus's lifetime than Islamic texts were
written to Muhammad's. Then, as if that
proves something I had ever disputed, I
never did. He asked rhetorically,
>> "With statistics like these, how can
Raymond suggest that Muhammad is more
much more historically supported than
Jesus?"
>> Of course, I never claimed that Muhammad
is much more historically supported than
Jesus, which is a broad and open-ended
assertion at best. Nor was I counting
the writings of believers such as the
New Testament, consistent with the
approach of mainstream historians. What
I actually said is this. Based on the
strict criteria of the historical method
and when comparing apples with apples,
not apples with oranges, that is by
examining writings about Jesus and
Muhammad from non-believers on both
sides. There are more and earlier
non-Muslim references to Muhammad than
there are non-Christian references to
Jesus. That's certainly not the same as
the sweeping claim he attributes to me
that quote Muhammad is much more
historically supported than Jesus. A
claim which by the way I reject since I
personally do accept the authority of
the New Testament. But of course and
considering that Jay was speaking before
a Christian audience, the whole point it
seems was to present me as casting doubt
on Christ's existence and thus win
brownie points via an ad hominemum
attack. Here's another of Jay Strawman.
In my video, I made it a point to say I
only believe in the barebone summary of
Muhammad's story as captured by those
early 7th century non-Muslim, mostly
Christian accounts. Let's start with me
laying out my personal beliefs
concerning Muhammad, whether he existed
or not.
I believe in the barebone facts of his
biography. I believe that sometime in
the early 7th century, a man claiming to
be a prophet arose in Arabia and became
dominant through warfare. Why do I
believe this? because we have several
remarkably early references to his
existence and all by non-Muslims.
Despite that, all throughout his
presentation, Jay presents me as a
staunch supporter of the standard
Islamic narrative, which he gives the
rather nifty acronym SIN. Standard
Islamic narrative. Good one, Jay. This
sin is entirely built upon the SA, the
Hadith, and many other later Muslim
writings. Writings which I expressly
cast doubt on. It's again for all these
reasons that as far as I'm concerned,
the barebone facts of Muhammad's
biography that a man claiming to be a
prophet and promising paradise to his
militant followers are by the standards
of history, not to mention common sense,
amply attested. Having said all that, I
do not necessarily believe in those many
details contained in the vast corpus of
Islam scriptures from Hak or biography
of Muhammad to the countless volumes of
hadith which Muslims believe contain the
detailed doings and teachings of their
prophet. For example, all throughout the
video, he keeps talking to a certain
Abdul in the audience. But let me ask
you, sir, you're going to be Abdul right
now, right? Abdul, you're happy. You're
a Muslim. You love that. What about
Jesus Christ? Don't we also have a
hadith of Jesus, the sayings of Jesus.
Don't we also have a sid of Jesus, the
biography of Jesus? Yes, we do, don't
we? For those of you who are Christian,
not you, Abdul. You're a Muslim. Okay,
stay a Muslim night.
But he also regularly conflates him with
me, saying things like, "You and Raymond
say at one point, after supposedly
proving that the standard Islamic
narrative, sin, is of dubious origin and
written much later than what most
historians believe," Jay yells out while
pointing to Abdul, "How are you going to
answer now, Raymond? Must I really
answer to something I never claimed?" As
for those 10 points he attributed to me
and because there's no time to go
through each one of them, let's just
quickly look at the last one number 10.
Quote, "The best pmic is to prove how
irrelevant Muhammad is for us today."
This Jay claims is what I believe here
in reality is what I said. Okay, so
you're an avowided foe of Islam who
would see it swept up in the dust bin of
history. Hence why you were so happy to
jump on the Muhammad never existed
bandwagon. So what now? I'll tell you
what now. Whoever is interested in
effectively opposing Islam must do so at
its own gain. That's the way it's always
been and the and the way it's always
going to be. You must embrace the Muslim
paradigm and accept Islam's first
premise that the Quran, the Sira,
Hadith, etc. in a word, Islam scriptures
do indeed contain the teachings of
Muhammad and his God. But then you must
show how such teachings contradict
reason, logic, decency, morality, and
especially godliness. such as the
original approach, the only tried and
true pmic that has from the first
century following Muhammad's death via
the writings of John of Damascus,
arguably history's first pmicist against
Islam, till the present moment been
challenging and convincing Muslims that
theirs is a false prophet. On the other
hand, merely insisting that he never
existed may be personally satisfying,
but it's also a way of putting yourself
out of the debate altogether, rendering
yourself totally moved. Now going back
to the claim that Jay attributes to me
that I believe that quote the best pmic
is to prove how irrelevant Muhammad is
for us today. Ask yourself who's really
trying to make Muhammad irrelevant? Me
based on what you just saw me saying or
Jay who wants you to believe that
Muhammad never even existed? Surely
something that never existed is by
definition the most irrelevant thing of
all. I can go on and on with examples of
Jay misrepresenting my position, but all
I'll say is if you're interested, fast
forward towards the end of his video,
starting around the hour 48 minute mark,
and you'll see all sorts of quotes,
actual statements with quotation marks
around them, which Jay attributes to me,
though I never said any of those things.
Go watch my two videos and try to prove
me wrong. For example, he says, "Raymond
therefore claims that quote, so this is
me talking. Since Muhammad is far more
historically supported than Jesus Christ
by denying his historicity, we are not
only being inconsistent but possibly
dishonest." That I never said this quote
is obvious in the simple fact that it
has me saying the word we, which is
clearly a reference to Jay and the other
nomos, who I presumably talk about, not
count myself among. It's obvious proof
that this quote attributed to me was
actually written by Jay or an assistant.
That said, I don't believe he was being
intentionally deceptive. I'll assume
it's a typo or a misplacing of quotation
marks. Anyway, so much for the first
video response Jay made. Now, a few days
later, I learned that he had made yet
another lengthy video in response to me.
Time is not a commodity for me and so I
was a bit hesitant about watching
another two hours of what I feared might
be more straw men bashing. But in the
name of Christian charity, I decided to
give it a go. And literally less than
two minutes into the video came this.
>> Abra Abraham. I don't know if you know
him, but he's
>> I googled him. He's a Egyptian. He's a
bodybuilder. And then he kind of looks
at the tradition of Islam. I kind of did
little bit of him before the live
stream. He's an Egyptian first, then
he's a bodybuilder second, then he is a
critique of Islam. So, taking that under
your wing, understand?
So, from straw man to ad homonym, that
is attacking the man instead of his
argument. I.e., Raymond Brahim is just a
meatthead bodybuilder. So, what does he
know? As for stressing that I'm Egyptian
first, I honestly don't know what his
point is in emphasizing my ethnic
background. Needless to say, I couldn't
go on at that point and clicked out.
Mind you, I wasn't upset. I actually had
a good chuckle at it, but it was enough
for me to
Hi there. I recorded what you just
watched a couple days after I had
watched Jay Smith's video, which came
out on July 9th, but then I put it aside
to edit later. Since then, I'm pleased
to announce that Jay has invited me to a
debate through a July 17 email from one
of his colleagues, apparently the same
one who was having a chuckle about my
being a bodybuilder over 30 years ago.
Well, here I am to say I happily accept.
I'd also like to say something else. I
never knew anything about J. Smith other
than that he was the leader of the
Nomos, as I call those who believe
Muhammad never existed, until I watched
that 2-hour video of him. And although I
was grieved by his misrepresentations of
what I said, I also couldn't help but
think that he was a good and jolly kind
of guy. And now by inviting me to a
debate, which I hardilyedly look forward
to, he's proven himself honorable as
well. So good for you, Jay.
Incidentally, I still decided to release
the previous footage, both because it
took time to make and because it saves
time. Now, I won't hopefully have to
waste any valuable debating time trying
to rebut Jay's initial charges, seeing
how I've already done so in the earlier
part of this video. Anyone among you who
plans on watching this forthcoming
debate, my only suggestion is that you
first watch my two short videos, the
ones that started this whole thing,
links in the description, simply so you
have a clear understanding of what my
actual claims are. Spoiler alert,
they're much less about proving that
Muhammad existed and much more about
evaluating the impact of saying he
didn't exist, including the very
negative impact it has on non-Muslims,
which I did not mention in my videos,
but will during our forthcoming debate.
Finally, and to show you Jay, what a
good sport I am, even though, and as I
explained in the first part of this
video, and as I made clear in my
original videos, my interest has only
been to argue for the existence of
Muhammad. And even though that is
something entirely different from saying
the standard Islamic narrative is
correct, a position which I already
rejected in my earlier videos, since you
do attribute it to me, I will happily
play devil's advocate and defend it in
our debate. In short, and at the sake of
validating your charge that I'm being
typically Arabic with my oneup man
showmanship style, I will be the sheh
Abdul that you associate me with, and I
will argue on behalf of the standard
Islamic narrative, not because I believe
it, but to show how difficult, if not
impossible, it is to get any Muslim to
disbelieve it. Why in the world is he
confronting me if he's not even looked
at my videos?
That shows you right away that the fact
that he hasn't even looked at our
argument suggests that he is either
naive or simply arrogant or is being
typically Arabic with his oneupmanship
style. I think it's the latter.
[Music]